I want to highlight another thing. Let's look at this
data. It looks kind of, strange, right? This data's actually
in JSON format. The same JSON that we discussed
earlier in this class. As I insinuated earlier, we can
kind of, think of JSON data as a Python
dictionary. Let's make this data easier to read and I'll
show you what I mean. See how each piece
of data in this JSON object corresponds to a key,
very much how like every value in a Python dictionary corresponds to a key. So
our first key here is album. And the value is actually another JSON object. Here
we have key name, value unapologetic, key
artist, value of Rihanna, and so on. Although
JSON is not equivalent to Python dictionaries,
you can think of them as similar abstractions.